coming up on 5 17 on your thursday
morning while more folks are flying the
passenger satisfaction is going down
that according to a study by j.d power
one of the reasons higher cost bureau of
labor statistics says airfares have gone
up more than 33 percent in the last year
the highest 12 month increase since 1980
another reason for dissatisfaction
planes are getting more crowded
the things that you probably need to to
work on are improving the comfort of the
aircraft in all cabin classes
and working on people skills to make
people feel less like cattle and more
like valued passengers i think
eliminating the salt lakes in the eye
would probably help there too the study
comes as airports and airlines are
gearing up for what is expected to be
another busy summer travel season in
fact they're saying passenger volume
could go back to pre-pandemic levels
and as a result the tsa says hey we're
investing in new technology trying to
speed up the travel process for your
vacation john yeah we'll see how that
goes